[Music]
halo 4 is going to be released this fall
and um they just announced it well i'll
tell you i'm really excited about this
because it turns out that i'm going to
be a part of halo 4. that's right yeah
thank you
basically here's how it works i recently
met with the halo design team this is
just a couple of days ago and i brought
along a camera crew to discuss my role
in halo 4 and it's all very exciting
here's what happened
hey this is pretty exciting i'm sitting
here with two of the brainchilds behind
halo 4
frank o'connor
who is the franchise director is that
correct yeah and uh kiki wolf kill
name that is an insane name that is
fantastic
so frank o'connor and kiki wolfkill yeah
so you're like a nordic
dragon slayer and you're her bartender
i'm not a gamester
i'm not a gamesman my last
video game that i was pretty good at was
pong
these are games
where
you can play with other people in the
world and you never know who you're
playing with is that right that's
correct okay have there been hookups
through halo yeah
marriages we've had people who walk down
the aisle to halo music so they take it
pretty seriously okay that's
sad
um
now guys you had offered to show me a
quick sample of the new halo 4 just to
familiarize myself with the with the
game yeah some top secret highly
confidential footage okay this is
footage that is not ready to be seen by
people correct so i'm going to take a
look at this
for you the viewing public we're going
to edit in
footage that's
close or similar to what you would see
but not the same
when we left the chief last he was
trapped aboard the frozen record for the
starship a drift in an unknown space and
coming into orbit
what is it that you're interested in
having me do there's a moment near the
end of the game where the master chief
is about to go into war and the last
thing he's going to see is a couple of
marines living a real moment and we felt
that you were just the voice that we
needed for at least one of those
characters do i have a gun
you will have you will have a weapon now
kind of can my character fire it um
you've chosen not to use it right you've
chosen to
a kind of thinker
so you're saying that my character does
not fight but any character can kill me
yes or no there's really no reason they
would do that
i don't think kids are just going to
automatically go whale on your character
unless they knew he would you didn't
have the right you didn't grow up the
way i did
okay people wailed on this character
plenty and for no reason
where am i uh you say i'm i'm doing some
kind of preparatory work let's be
specific here you are in a massive
hangar on the largest most powerful
starship that humanity has ever built it
just sounds like a loading dock it
is somewhat of a loading dock
i'm on a loading dock
i'm on a death star
i'm hoping to load stuff before you are
surrounded by very important equipment
i'm a clerk
and a loading dog
and i'm a very i'm a coward i have a gun
but i don't know how to use it
just nod your head if that's the essence
of it
yes thank you and
thank you
i had a thought to make this character a
little more conan o'brien all right
which are you guys okay
if this is
i do like the personality yeah coming
through
so what if we even went a step further
and you could just get
like oh what is
this is a cool thing to be in halo for i
don't want to be completely anonymous
are you open to this idea and be honest
parts of it yes
parts meaning this part yeah that part
is great we could just put a kind of a
gold or a silver visor over it that
would hide my face it would protect your
face
if i can't show my face
are you guys open to this concept that
i'm holding a sign do you think this
would interfere with my clerical work on
the death shift
subtle you do need to be able to hold
crates i got you to admit i'm loading
crates
can i use different pitches and tones or
do you want to use my real voice or do a
character what kind of character do you
have in mind do you have an accent
[Applause]
it's great
[Music]
yeah
look at these crates
gotta get them loaded up
i wish i hadn't smoked as a child
a blender crease
[Laughter]
okay i get killed fast
eyes on men listen that'll never make
air
i had a thought i have a friend
who
is
fantastic at voice over work he's got
the best pipes in the business he's a
natural hollywood type
big hollywood type hot
big hollywood type
andy come on in all right
andy's worked in a lot of animation he's
the voice of mr quibbles on the quabble
hour right right uh we did peanut
mcnulty right in the jub jub show live
tour six squad floor six and the squad
four seven show which is an ironic name
let's proceed to the booth
and let's record these voices what do
you say let's make some art what'd you
say let's make some art no no let's just
record us okay
are we all set all right all right you
just tell us what you want we're pros
and we'll give it to you
so the basic setup is that you are in
the this hanger in the loading section
you're standing near some crates uh
working on logistics for the hangar bay
it'll be good to get these crates loaded
the crates are important for the battle
they'll need crates for the battle right
i think these are mostly uh front-line
office supplies
my crate says snacks
various snacks
they probably wouldn't miss a few if you
know what i'm saying
i already opened my crate a little bit
i took out some space peanuts
my father thinks i'm a coward
well i think he's right
i'm sorry i didn't hear what you were
saying i was peeing in my suit
look everybody it's master chief all
right
let's hear it from master chief what a
dick
would you crack my back for me sure i'll
just get my knee in here oh
yeah that's beautiful thank you this is
a pretty sweet union we're in that's
fine stand near the crates right but
don't ever move them right
who is the keys to this thing anyway
do you have the keys to it no
well how are we supposed to get these
crates in there if we can't open the
back door i know this is what you'd call
a design glitch
[Music]
i sure hate my life
i started taking antidepressants about
six weeks ago oh really yeah
so i mean bit it now oh
hey it's not like i'm getting any action
anyway exactly
back to standing still yep
i guess if we stand here long enough
someone will kill us who would be jerky
enough to do that and if they did kill
us
i'm sure they'd show our bodies
only the ultimate respect yeah
no victory crouching on our faces nope
time to go on break
can we just get you guys making sounds
like people are pummeling you with the
butt they're right sure oh ow oh hey
what ow cut
[Laughter]
oh
you hurt my feelings
[Applause]
good times